es hätte elf heute live herzlich
willkommen nach 20 jahren zieht die
bundeswehr aus afghanistan ab derwesten
erklärt seinen militäreinsatz dort für
beendet
heute sind die letzten 264 bundeswehr
soldatinnen und soldaten in wunstorf bei
hannover angekommen
drei transportflugzeuge vom typ a400m
der luftwaffe sind dort nacheinander
gelandet der letzte deutsche kommandeur
in afghanistan ansgar meyer
verabschiedete die männer und frauen mit
den worten mission accomplished sie
haben ihren auftrag erfüllt tja was hat
dieser einsatz gebracht darüber sprechen
wir hier und heute und ich freue mich an
dieser stelle wie immer über ihre und
eure fragen und kommentare wie immer in
die kommentare in den sozialen medien
oder wenn ihr und sie uns eine e mail
schreiben möchte dann nutzt bitte und
damit gehe ich auch schon direkt zum du
über und hoffe das ist für alle in
ordnung an die dann hoffentlich
demnächst eingeblendete oder vielleicht
auch schon bekannte e mail adresse mit
dem eindruck der einsatz bestehe darin
in afghanistan brunnen zu bohren und
schulen zu bauen ist diese mission
gestartet aber heute 59 tote soldatinnen
und soldaten und viele verletzte
soldaten und soldatinnen später weiß man
am hindukusch ging es um leben und tod
und einer der das auf ganz besondere
weise erfahren musste ist heute bei uns
in der sendung mike mutzke ist einer von
denen die damals dort als soldat gedient
haben und 2010 schwer verwundet wurden
helmut schön dass sie heute abend bei
uns in der sendung sind wenn sie die
bilder sehen von den gelandeten
kameradinnen und kameraden heute vom
ende dieses einsatzes was geht ihnen
durch den kopf was soll ich sagen was
geht mir da durch den kopf wenn ich
dasselbe jetzt die maschinen gelandet
sind
ich bin glücklich über jeden der heil
unversehrt nach hause gekommen ist und
ich denke es ist auf einer zeit gewesen
dass wir jetzt alle zu hause sind
zu der frage wie sie das persönlich
einschätzen ob sich dieser einsatz
gelohnt hat ob es das alles wert war
kommen wir gleich
ich möchte aber gerne noch auf ihre
persönliche geschichte eingehen sie sind
am zweiten april 2010 während eines
einsatzes in den hinterhalt geraten
drei deutsche und sechs afghanische
soldaten wurden damals getötet können
sie uns erzählen was damals passiert ist
ja ich kann das ganz gut erzählen damals
nur wir sind damals rausgefahren so
portfolio bzw zu einem liebsten all dies
gibt einfach mal erklärt ist eine
versteckte oder sind oder benjamin oder
versteckte lademann was die taliban nur
vernichtung oder auch zum schluss sich
für sich selbst verbrachte er irgendwo
in fahrzeugen oder halt einfach auch öko
bauern gebaut meint die sowohl sticks
bauern bzw in deutschland sagt man dazu
zaun hat in dieser situation und werden
mit der auftrag haus gewesen damals die
zum fahren in dieses dorf isa k s bieten
beziehungsweise zu und versuchen dort
solche sprengfallen fahrer geheim sind
und da haben wir den auftrag dieses
durchzuführen und hatten damit als eine
drohne dabei gehabt mit dem nach dem
namen karol die uns dann damen als
abhandelt ums beziehungsweise von einem
funksignal abgerissen ist
und daraus dann die idee bzw der aufbau
diese drohne wieder zu suchen
beziehungsweise zu werden und aus dieser
ganzen situation ist denn dieses gefecht
am hals entstanden
wir wurden damals von den taliban
angegriffen
in einer kleinen gruppe also einem
später ein bisschen voraus geschoben
wird sein ob kräften sind dort ins feuer
geraten und hatten dort in den ersten
schwerstverletzten hat ein leicht
verletzten
ja und von dort aus sind wieder halb
zurück haben wir verletzten versucht
mehrere dinge zu bergen was auch
geklappt hätten dann aber während dieser
phase ist schon wieder den zweiten
verletzten wäre dann damals an seiner
verletzungen verstorben war
ja und ganz zum schluss wo wir dann halt
eigentlich komplett mit dem zug
ausweichen wollten gab es dann diese
riesen sensation wo es mich dann selbst
schwer verletzt hat und wir dann dabei
auch in dieser situation zwei gefallenen
kameraden
sie haben es angesprochen sie sind
selbst schwer verwundet worden wie haben
sie diesen einsatz verarbeitet und wenn
sie heute darauf zurückblicken
wie geht es ihnen heute und wie bewerten
sie das nämlich dass selbst verarbeitet
also ich für mich selber habe damals
mein schicksal über ein gewisses
zeitfenster erst mal versucht selbst zu
verarbeiten zu verstehen also mich
selbst verstehen was passiert auch um
ist das passiert was ist selber mit mir
passiert wie geht es mir wie komme ich
jetzt weiter an im leben und was wir
selbst aus mir werden und dann muss ich
sagen habe ich das jetzt ganz gut
hinbekommen aber auch keine weiteren
großen problem da sag ich jetzt mal man
hat schon mal ohne
jetzt höre ich und sehe ich dass wir
herrn mutzke nicht mehr hören und auch
nicht mehr zumindest nicht im bewegtbild
sehen können ich höre gerade wir
brauchen ein bisschen um die leitung
wieder herzustellen und in der zeit
blicken wir auf die lage wie sie sich in
afghanistan darstellt wie sie sich in
den vergangenen 20 jahren dargestellt
hat julia schröter fast den einsatz der
bundeswehr dort für uns zusammen fast 20
jahre lang waren deutsche streitkräfte
in afghanistan unter führung der nato im
einsatz vor allem im norden des landes
wichtigster stützpunkt war das camp
marmal in masar i scharif
insgesamt war die bundeswehr 7119 tage
vor ort mit über die jahre gerechnet
rund 150000 soldatinnen und soldaten 59
kamen ums leben
35 davon bei gefechten oder anschlägen
ursprünglich ging es bei dem einsatz um
friedenssicherung schließlich wurde er
zu einer art kampfeinsatz gegen die
radikalislamischen taliban
zuletzt ging es um ausbildung die
soldatinnen haben im rahmen der mission
resolute port afghanische
sicherheitskräfte geschult und jetzt
sind wir wieder bei herrn mutzke und
sehen die leitung ist stabil und bleibt
es hoffentlich auch helmut sorry für die
für die unterbrechung ich würde gern da
weitermachen wo wir wo wir aufgehört
haben und aber auch eine frage noch mit
einfließen lassen die ein zuschauer hier
an sie direkt stellt punkt weg fragt
über youtube bereuen sie es soldat
geworden zu sein nachdem sie verwundet
worden
ich würde auch wie viele mich fragen ob
ich stelle mir was den einsatz gehen
würde bzw ob ich jemandem die schuld für
das gibt was bei uns passiert ist immer
wieder nein und ich würde das genauso
wieder tun wie ich es damals getan habe
und ich bin auch bereit wieder zu gehen
egal wohin
sie haben ganz persönlich einen sehr
sehr hohen beitrag geleistet sie haben
sehr hohen preis gezahlt und sie haben
unvorstellbares dort erlitten und
erfahren und gesehen was aus ihrer ganz
persönlichen sicht hat dieser einsatz
gebracht das ist eine schwere frage ich
sage meine situation damals für uns
machen halt diesen aufbau und wem das
noch zu wagen und für dieses zeitfenster
hat muss man sagen 2010 und um diese
zeit gibt also bis 2013 war hat sich
doch schon gut was verbessert gut
stabilisiert in dieser ganzen lage ist
danach sich entwickelt hat kann man
nicht wirklich sagen und darauf will ich
mich auch einfach gar nicht groß war
dazu äußern kann jetzt auch ein blick
gar nicht weil ich da den überblick so
gar nicht habe dann wird das über die
zeit sehen was ist gebracht hat nun er
hat die bundeswehr ja noch viele andere
einsätze auch wenn dieser jetzt beendet
ist es gibt insgesamt zwölf aktuelle
bundeswehreinsätze auf drei kontinenten
den vielen ländern und kriegsgebieten
dieser welt was aus ihrer persönlichen
erfahrung heraus sollte man aus diesen
20 jahren in afghanistan lernen was
sonst noch alles lernen dass die zeit
hat immer wieder irgendwo ständig
gewinnen würde
und aus seiner sicht der sieger ist noch
mal zu ihrer ganz persönlichen
einstellung sie sind hingegangen
wahrscheinlich mit einem hohem
idealismus und sind dann in dieser
realität gelandet hätte ihnen das eher
geholfen wenn man von vorneherein gesagt
hätte es geht nicht um brunnen bohren
sondern es ist ein kampfeinsatz es ist
ein harter einsatz
es wird ein einsatz sein der tote
fordern wird und wir als deutsche
gesellschaft müssen uns auch damit
auseinandersetzen
wäre das eine diskussion die aus ihrer
sicht den soldaten und soldatinnen im
einsatz geholfen hätte und auch jetzt
aktuell hilft wenn man wahrheiten ins
auge schaut die sich zb ja auch in mali
stellen wie wir letzte woche gesehen
haben ja aus meiner sicht würde ich das
schon so einschätzen das wäre schon
besser weil man genau wüsste was ist
eigentlich der auftrag ist und nicht
liest an und genießt ja es geht um
schule
und es geht um den boden ausbauen wenn
er wirklich gesagt hätte dass sein kampf
einsatz gewesen wäre hätte man erstens
vom kopf her ist man und wo weiter kann
sich auch ganz andere sachen einstellen
wie das muss ich einfach nur auf und
welche sicher dass aufträge einstellen
herr mutschke ich danke ihnen ganz
herzlich dass sie mit dieser sehr
persönlichen sicht auf diesen krieg
heute bei uns in der sendung waren
vielen dank und alles gute für sie und
wir machen weiter mit unserem nächsten
gesprächspartner der auch diesen einsatz
sehr eng begleitet hat so kann man das
sagen
der nato general egon ramms ist uns
zugeschaltet ehemaliger chef des isaf
einsatzes in afghanistan und damit einer
der ranghöchsten deutschen soldaten in
der nato
ramms diese gesellschaftspolitische
debatte haben sie die auch 20 jahre lang
vermisst das was herr mutzke gerade
sagte das hätte ihm persönlich als
soldat im kampf vor ort geholfen
wie sehen sie das aus ihrer sicht als
befehlshaber
also ich hätte mir aus meiner rolle von
sowas operativer befehlshaber gewünscht
dass die bevölkerung der bundesrepublik
deutschland an diesem einsatz intensiver
teilnimmt und vielleicht auch die
politik diesen einsatz gegenüber der
bevölkerung detaillierter genauer
beschrieben und begründet hätte die
helmut gefallen sagte wir sind dorthin
gegangen
deutschland ist dort hingegangen im
jahre 2002 mit
unter der überschrift schulen bauen und
brunnen bohren und das hat sich
spätestens ab 2007 war der anschlag in
kundus gezeigt dass das nicht der ganze
auftrag war und wir hatten auch vorher
schon gefallene soldaten
als die bundeswehr noch in kabul war von
daher wäre sage ich mal ganz vorsichtig
eine diskussion zu dem thema was ist der
einsatz in afghanistan in deutschland
mit der gesellschaft mit der bevölkerung
und auch die unterstützung für die
soldaten zu bekommen
sicherlich ein sinnvoller ansatz gewesen
2007 hatten wir einen anschlag in kundus
auch danach durfte noch nicht in
deutschland vom krieg geredet werden
dort wurde durchaus von der regierung
etwas unfreundlich angenommen nun
blicken wir auf das was dieser krieg
gebracht hat was dieser einsatz gebracht
hat da gibt es eine frage von einem user
namens strong vale spricht das jetzt mal
so aus über youtube er beantwortet die
frage ob es der einsatzwert war mit der
antwort schwierig zu sagen sonderlich
verbessert hat sich die lage jetzt
vielleicht nicht aber wer weiss wie die
lage in der region heute aussehen würde
ohne den einsatz was ist ihr fazit hat
der westen sein ziel erreicht
der westen hat sein ziel ist er sich
2002 gestellt hat nicht aber es steht
für mich fest wobei da muss man jetzt ja
deutlich differenzieren und
unterscheiden zwischen dem was man
politisch vorgehabt hat und das wofür
man soldaten nach afghanistan geschickt
hat ich unterstreiche das was der letzte
kommando support heute gesagt hat er mir
gesagt hat dass die soldaten ihren
auftrag erfüllt haben
aber wir hatten ja auch einen
erheblichen zivilen anteil der dort
geleistet werden sollte vielleicht auch
zu anfang mit falschen vorstellungen das
ist dann irgendwann komponiert worden
aber insgesamt muss man sagen hat die
zivile und militärische zusammenarbeit
zwischen den vereinten nationen vielen
regierungs und
nichtregierungsorganisationen der
militärischen seite nicht so geklappt
wie es hätte sein sollen
und das lag nicht an den soldaten das
lag daran was die ziele seit ich sage
dass wir ganz einfach dafür keinen
masterplan gehabt dann trotzdem ist
afghanistan umgestaltet worden für einer
demokratie trotzdem hat man den frauen
in afghanistan geholfen
trotzdem hat man die kindersterblichkeit
gesenkt die geburtenrate deutlich
verbessert von daher gibt es
fortschritte die durch diesen einsatz in
allen möglichen bereichen entstanden
sind
aber das ganz große ziel afghanistan zu
einem demokratischen befriedeten von
taliban befreite staat zu verwandeln das
ist nicht gelungen
wenn sie sich jetzt den zeitpunkt
angucken wo vieles von dem was sie
gerade als positiv genannt haben schon
wieder passé ist also die taliban sind
auf dem vormarsch
die angst vor einem bürgerkrieg in
afghanistan
ist da das ist er aktuell die lage in
der wir uns befinden wo dieser abzug
stattfindet was ist das für ein timing
wie willkürlich ist das wie gut wir
richtig wie falsch ist es jetzt
ausgerechnet zu sagen wir gehen also ich
möchte kleinlich zurückblicken bin ich
darf wir haben die situation gehabt dass
der damalige com auf david mckiernan der
kommen als aus dem die christen im jahr
2008 2009 eine verstärkung der truppen
in afghanistan gefordert haben
die auch dann eingetreten ist mit der
entscheidung von barack obama im jahre
2009 ende 2009 2010
wir haben 2010 2011 in afghanistan
relativ gute erfolgreiche jahre ja was
dem bereich der sicherheit angehen
danach begann der von obama bereits
angekündigte abzug bis hin zum ende von
isaf auch angekündigt im jahr 2009
dezember 2009 im jahr 2014 damals haben
viele leute gesagt die taliban können
sich jetzt den wecker stellen für anfang
2015 und dann können sie wieder anfangen
und eine ähnliche entwicklung haben wir
tatsächlich verfolgt von daher steht
fest für mich dass der abzug von einsatz
zu früh erfolgt ist das ist der eine
teil dabei und wir sind jetzt in einer
ähnlichen situation
die friedensverhandlungen die donald
trump mit den taliban hat durchführen
lassen indoor haben keinen erfolg
gebracht die taliban haben nicht
eingelenkt die anzahl der anschläge hat
sich wieder erhöht und der selbst sehr
schnelle und überraschende abzug der
präsident der amerikaner beiden jetzt
entschieden hat kam für viele
überraschend aus dem grund da war es
gibt es ein hastiger abzog und ich
glaube genauso wie bei sagt auch dieses
ende von report kommt zu füllen wir
soldaten ich sage absichtlich ihr
soldaten weil es viele waren
beispielsweise david petraeus
beispielsweise auch stände christ und
ich selber auch
wir haben im jahr 2010 immer wieder
darauf aufmerksam gemacht dass ein
solcher abzug lageabhängig erfolgen muss
und er ist erfolgt aus innenpolitischen
gründen in den usa aus innenpolitischen
gründen in deutschland oder aus gründen
die in vielen anderen ländern auch in
der innenpolitik gelegen
und die bevölkerung oder der bevölkerung
nicht mehr zumuten wollte diesen einsatz
weiter zu unterstützen den man ihr aber
vorher auch nicht entsprechend
vermittelt hatte wenn man den blick
weitet auf die anderen einsatzorte und
zum beispiel mali anschaut ich habe es
gerade schon angesprochen wir alle haben
den anschlag von vergangener woche noch
vor augen sieht man da dass sich fehler
auf aus afghanistan wiederholen also
eingreifen stabilisieren fortschritte
machen rückschläge einstecken und dann
raus gehen erleben sie das in ähnlicher
form wieder und bedauern sie dass man
nicht mehr aus afghanistan gelernt hat
also man kann jeder von der größe des
einsatzes noch vom auftrag her
afghanistan mit marie vergleichen
marley - da wo jetzt ja anschlag erfolgt
das ist ein un einsatz mit einer etwas
anderen ich sag mal richtig dabei nicht
hauptsächlich auch einen
ausbildungsauftrag mit dabei und mali
ist auf anderer basis entstanden
ich erinnere daran dass wir in
afghanistan in spitzenzeiten 49
beteiligten nationen gehabt haben und
insgesamt 140.000 soldaten im einsatz
gehabt dann von daher hat marie eine
andere qualität
trotzdem auch in diesem einsatz gilt wir
müssen der zivilen seite die möglichkeit
geben zum wiederaufbau des landes für
die rekonstruktion für die herstellung
der wirtschaft um der gleiche wäre das
kostet viel zeit und dessen ist man sich
in afghanistan auch bewusst gewesen
hier hat man in mali dafür erneut muss
ich jetzt allerdings sagen keine
zeitlimits oder zeitgrenzen oder zwei
ziele gesetzt hat die haben noch bei der
zweiten petersberg konferenz über
afghanistan im jahr und 2011 offiziell
beschlossen dass wir die afghanen
wiederaufbau des landes und dazu gehört
auch sicherung siehe resolution port
beispielsweise ist 2024 unterstützen
wollen denn mein kalender richtig geht
haben wir jetzt mit 2021
deutsche kriegseinsätze sind seit 30
jahren seitdem es sie wieder gibt höchst
umstritten auch in der politik mali aus
afghanistan sowieso wir schauen mal auf
eine politische stimme die heute sich
zum thema geäußert hat von vielen
politischen stimmen aber diese eine
greifen wir mal raus und zwar von agnes
strack zimmermann von der fdp jetzt muss
uns die bundesregierung klar machen was
für ziele werden uns noch erwarten und
sind diese realistisch und sind unsere
soldaten und soldatinnen wirklich gut
genug ausgerüstet letzteres bezweifeln
wir ja und das in bezug auf welchen
konflikt auch immer dazu eine meinung
von definitely not immer über youtube
deutschland sollte sich nie für andere
länder und deren probleme in konflikte
ziehen lassen das ist die bilanz
deutsche soldaten sterben für nichts
ramms für was aus ihrer sicht sollten
deutsche soldaten ihr leben riskieren
für welche einsätze was ist das ziel der
bundeswehr
also es geht nicht um das ziel der
bundeswehr so dass geht um ein politisch
gestecktes ziel für das politisch
gesteckte ziel müssen die entsprechenden
voraussetzungen gesetzt werden das heißt
die soldaten die dann in den einsatz
gehen müssten in die lage versetzt
werden ihre aufträge zu erfüllen und das
beginnt bei einer guten ausbildung für
die soldaten das geht weiter über sagt
man eine hinreichende truppenstärke das
geht weiter über die entsprechende
ausrüstung und ich muss frau strack
zimmermann an dieser stelle recht geben
mit dem was sie gerade gesagt hat und
ich stelle mir vor dass habe ich mir
vorhin mal überlegt wie das gewesen wenn
bei dem karfreitags gefecht der
bewaffnete drohnen gehabt hätten nun
möglicherweise auf die angriffe der
taliban mit bewaffneten drohnen netten
reagieren können nicht nur zum schutz
unserer soldaten auch um die taliban
auszuschalten
auch das ist etwas wo wir uns daran
gewöhnen müssen und wo die politik die
verpflichtung hat auch die gesellschaft
entsprechend zu informieren und dann
solche prozessoren gedankengängen zu
gewöhnen weil wir sind nicht allein auf
der welt wir sind doch nicht die schweiz
deutschland ist ein land weg ist eine
zentrale geostrategische lage hat
welches verpflichtung in der welt hat
welches link vom bild handelt vom export
und dergleichen
das heißt wir müssen auch in der lage
sein die damit verknüpften militärischen
aufgaben ausführen zu können
das heißt nicht dass ich sie ausführen
will oder herbei reden will
aber wir müssen dieses mittel militär
mit einer guten ausrüster mit der
entsprechenden personalstärke und gut
ausgebildeten personal haben wenn wir
das politisch einsetzen wollen sagt der
nato general egon ramms vielen
herzlichen dank dass sie heute abend bei
uns in der sendung waren und wir haben
im laufe des gesprächs viel darüber
erfahren wie der einsatz der bundeswehr
dort gelaufen ist und welche chancen und
risiken darin gelegen haben und welche
herausforderungen die bundeswehr nun
angehen muss im rückblick und auch auf
die zukunft ausgerichtet und jetzt
schauen wir in das land in dem die
bundeswehr 20 jahre lang unterwegs war
nach afghanistan wie ist die lage dort
im moment und was droht den afghaninnen
und afghanen wenn die westlichen
soldaten abgezogen sind
unsere korrespondentin katrin eigendorf
war dort letzte woche zuletzt unterwegs
und hier sind die eindrücke die sie
mitgebracht hat machtdemonstration so
wie hier in gasen die posieren taliban
kämpfer in vielen afghanischen provinzen
die verhandlungen mit der regierung in
kabul liegen auf eis die aufständischen
sind im krieg selbst in masar i scharif
wo die bundeswehr ihren stützpunkt hat
sind die kämpfer bis an die stadtgrenze
vorgerückt die afghanische armee ist zum
wichtigsten angriffsziel der taliban
geworden seitdem die usa ihren abzug aus
afghanistan verkündet haben jetzt
bereiten sich soldaten überall im land
auf krieg vor
in einer nationalen offensive will die
regierung die aufständischen zurück
schlagen vor allem frauen fürchten nun
überall im land ihre rechte zu verlieren
afghanistans erster frei gewählter
präsident hamid karsai erklärte im
interview mit dem zdf er wolle
versöhnung mit den taliban
doch frauenrechte seien nicht
verhandelbar
die rechte die währungen haben die
freiheit die wir haben müssen wir
schützen
besonders die bildung unserer mädchen
dieses recht werden wir mit allen
mitteln verteidigen
der kampf ist in mehr als der hälfte des
landes verloren
in den provinzen in denen taliban ihr
schatten regime etabliert haben und
jetzt bin ich sehr froh dass katrin
eigendorf bei uns hier im studio ist
kathrin schön dass sie da sind und dass
sie den beitrag mitgebracht haben und
auch über eine ganz lange zeitspanne
berichten können in der sie afghanistan
bereits haben und von dort berichtet
haben als der einsatz begann war
afghanistan ein land in dem frauen
gesteinigt wurden und der politische
gegner umgebracht wurde
wie sehen sie das land heute also man
muss einfach diese entwicklung sehen ich
war das erste mal 2004 in afghanistan da
war das land wirklich noch in einer
phase des aufbruchs wo auch von seiten
der bevölkerung dieser militärische und
zivile einsatz sehr positiv gesehen
wurde
das war einfach die zeit wo afghanistan
wirklich die chance hatte sich zu einer
demokratie zu entwickeln
heute habe ich in den letzten zwei
wochen ich bin sonntag aus afghanistan
zurückgekommen ein land erlebt das
wirklich muss ich sagen am rande eines
bürgerkrieges steht die taliban sind
überall auf dem vormarsch sie
kontrollieren inzwischen mehr
territorium als die regierung haben dort
ein schatten regime aufgebaut und
natürlich fürchten viele afghanen jetzt
darum dass die wenigen errungenschaften
muss man ja sagen die das land erlebt
hat in den letzten 20 jahren jetzt auf
dem spiel stehen
ich glaube dass der zeitpunkt des abzugs
nicht hätte unglücklicher gewählt sein
können und die tatsache dass der
amerikanische präsident den elfter
september als zeitpunkt des abzugs
gewählt hat zeigt er im prinzip welche
motive dem zugrunde liegen nämlich das
motiv dass amerika damals nach
afghanistan gegangen ist um al-qaida zu
verjagen oder im prinzip ein zu
verhindern dass das land noch mal ein
safe haven für für terroristen werden
kann
und das steht natürlich die frage
ging es wirklich um die demokratisierung
afghanistans oder nicht eher um die
frage wie sich an die amerikaner ihr
land und wenn man da mal eine bilanz
zieht glaube ich hat man aus den
falschen schritten jetzt die falschen
konsequenzen gezogen die tatsache dass
zum beispiel die amerikaner jetzt
hingegangen sind das hat ja donald trump
noch begonnen aber wird ja auch von joe
biden politisch unterstützt hingegangen
sind und die taliban an den
verhandlungstisch geholt haben und mit
den taliban gespräche über die zukunft
afghanistans geführt haben ohne die
regierung die gewählte regierung
afghanistans an diesen gesprächen zu
beteiligen
das halte ich für einen eklatanten
fehler der sich jetzt im prinzip im land
bemerkbar macht die taliban nutzen das
machtvakuum jetzt um sich im prinzip mit
gewalt zurück an die macht zu kämpfen
es gibt eine landläufige meinung die man
auch hier in den in den kommentaren
manchmal lesen kann einer schreibt zb
leider ist es realität dass manche
länder gar keine freiheitliche
demokratie haben wollen afghanistan
gehört dazu
sie haben diese menschen dort vor ort
erlebt und kennengelernt
wie kommentieren sie das das halte ich
für einen völlig falschen rückschluss
aus den letzten 20 jahren der geschichte
afghanistans also das ist ja eine fast
kolonialistische handhaltung also als ob
es länder gebe die demokratie nicht
wollen und andere dieser wohl dazu in
der lage sind
ich denke es gibt in afghanistan sehr
wohl kräfte die eine demokratische
entwicklung des landes wollen die frage
ist kann man militärisch als nato als
westen wir als deutsche ein land auf
einen weg der demokratisierung bringen
das ist natürlich sehr problematisch und
problematisch ist auch dass wir diesen
einsatz begonnen haben mit eigentlich
großer unkenntnis vor allem die
amerikaner den werfen
ja viele afghanen heute vor dass sie im
prinzip die bevölkerung des landes
hinter bekämpft haben also viele leute
wurden umgebracht indem verdacht taliban
zu sein den die taliban waren ja die
amerikaner sind in dieses land gegangen
mit erschütternder unkenntnis muss man
sagen und was ich heute erlebe auch in
gesprächen mit menschen also sowohl
menschen die sagen mal für eine
demokratische entwicklung eintreten aber
auch konservative die machen einen
großen unterschied zwischen den
amerikanern in deutschen also die
deutschen haben in afghanistan muss ich
sagen noch ein relativ positives ansehen
weil wir eben oder deutschland versucht
hat vor allem in die zivile entwicklung
zu investieren also der ansatz brunnen
bauen das war sicherlich schon der
richtige dass deutschland von der
realität am boden eingeholt wurde ist
natürlich eine entwicklung die man heute
einfach kritisch betrachten muss und
analysieren muss im prinzip sind die
deutschen militärs in einen krieg
hineingezogen wurden und der große
fehler ist dass man das nicht früh genug
benannt hat das wurde ja jetzt schon
öfter thematisiert dass man lange aus
lange versucht hat die bevölkerung im
prinzip im unklaren über die realität am
boden in afghanistan zu lassen und das
ist natürlich vor allem für die soldaten
sehr frustrierend gewesen kann nicht
mehr vorstellen
es gibt hier sehr viele kommentare auch
zu den afghanischen helferinnen und
helfern die die bundeswehr vor ort
unterstützt haben und die jetzt
natürlich ein großes problem haben wenn
die bundeswehr abzieht sonja hirte
schreibt zum beispiel über facebook der
einsatz hat nichts gebracht 20 jahre und
jetzt die menschen die mit uns
zusammengearbeitet haben müssen um ihr
leben fürchten und die taliban brauchen
nicht lange um das land wieder ins
mittelalter zu bomben zu schießen und zu
morden
bevor wir dazu kommen wäre jetzt dieses
machtvakuum dort vielleicht übernehmen
wird also stichwort taliban
was ist denn mit den helferinnen und
helfern und warum konnte man das nicht
rechtzeitig regeln und warum müssen die
tatsächlich jetzt um ihr leben fürchten
wie geht es den menschen dar
also wir haben ich habe persönlich mit
vielen helfern gesprochen die meisten
von denen leben natürlich in masar i
scharif in dem haupt einsatzort der
bundeswehr
das problem ist dass man deren nöte
nicht rechtzeitig erkannt hat und im
prinzip zu große bürokratische hürden
aufgebaut hat das was besonders
frustrierend für viele vor allem
übersetzer ist dass sie gar nicht wissen
welchen genauen weg sie gehen müssen was
sind die anlaufstellen ja es gibt ja im
prinzip kein konsulat mehr der deutschen
dann kommt dazu als punkt dass man
nachweisen muss dass man von den taliban
bedroht wird also da hat es ja ein
gesprächspartner gesagt soll ich einen
lebendigen taliban jetzt vorführen um
eine bedrohung nachzuweisen
das ist natürlich sehr schwierig auf der
anderen seite muss man sehen dass zum
jetzigen zeitpunkt sehr sehr viele
afghanen das land verlassen möchten und
verständlicherweise verlassen möchten
weil wer möchte nicht in sicherheit
leben und dass natürlich deutschland
auch diese anliegen sorgfältig prüfen
muss also das denke ich ist ein
zweigleisiges schwert aber trotzdem
denke ich hätte man bürokratische hürden
nehmen können und die prozesse deutlich
vereinfachen können ich glaube es ist
jetzt schon so dass ein drittel aller
flüchtlinge die nach deutschland kommen
aus afghanistan stammen welches
interesse sollte denn deutschland haben
weiter in afghanistan aktiv zu sein
nun ich denke die mission die
deutschland begonnen hat alleine macht
es schon nötig dass wir das land weiter
auf dem schirm haben und es ist ja auch
nicht so dass mit dem abzug der
bundeswehr jetzt deutschlands engagement
in afghanistan endet es gibt viele
hilfsorganisationen die gesagt haben
dass sie in afghanistan bleiben werden
die auch weiter dort die brunnen bauen
die schulen bauen ganz kurze
zwischenfrage dazu es gibt vereinzelt
die meinung dass hilfsorganisationen
dass es schwerer haben es leichter haben
so rum leichter hört sich paradox an
weil leichter wenn die bundeswehr
abgezogen ist wie schätzen sie das ein
das lässt sich finde ich so pauschal
nicht sagen also natürlich bedeutet auch
für die hilfsorganisationen die im land
tätig sind dieses machtvakuum die
tatsache dass sich regierungstruppen und
taliban überall kämpfen
liefern dass dieses land im prinzip eine
regierung hat die eigentlich gar keinen
rückhalt mehr hat keine macht mehr
ausübt dass das betrifft natürlich auch
die arbeit von hilfsorganisationen also
ich habe selber in masar-i-scharif mit
einem mitarbeiter gesprochen der für
deutschland dort strom in die stadt
gebracht hat der seit vielen jahren dort
tätig ist man muss sich vorstellen das
sind leute die fahren mittlerweile mit
einem gepanzerten fahrzeug durch die
stadt die sind schwer bewacht die leben
im prinzip hinter gittern und können
sich gar nicht mehr frei bewegen im land
also das ist schon eine tatsache seit
längerer zeit und das wird sich
natürlich noch deutlich verschlechtern
deswegen finde ich diese aussage kann
man so pauschal nicht treffen das ist
für die hilfsorganisationen leichter
wird ich denke die auch die taliban sind
so klug dass sie wissen es ist ein
unterschied gibt zwischen der
militärischen präsenz des westens im
land und der zivilen und die zivile
präsenz ist auch von den taliban
gewünscht unter bestimmten bedingungen
natürlich
sie haben das machtvakuum angesprochen
was befürchten sie was welche macht
werden die taliban einnehmen und der es
also die taliban sind natürlich im
moment weiter auf dem vormarsch
ich habe das gesagt sie kontrollieren
mittlerweile mehr territorium als die
regierung
das große problem ist dass die
verhandlungen die eigentlich zu einer
einigung führen sollten einer vielleicht
interimsregierung neuwahlen völlig
stocken
denn die taliban lehnen die regierung
die gewählte regierung afghanistans ab
und fordern den rücktritt von präsident
gar nie präsident ghani hat jetzt
mehrfach gesagt dass er nicht
zurücktreten wird sondern im prinzip
eine politische lösung auf dem
verhandlungsweg möglich ist das stockt
die situation die bs gerade haben ist
dass taliban und regierungstruppen sich
überall im land kämpfe liefern was
besonders problematisch ist
die regierung hat ja der vergangenen
woche als die taliban im prinzip schon
vor masar i scharif stand einer stadt
die eigentlich als relativ sicher galt
dazu aufgerufen dass sich überall im
land
die bevölkerung zu einer offensive an
der seite der armee zusammen tun muss
das heißt aufruf dazu alte milizenführer
wieder in den krieg zu schicken der
aufruf sogar bürger mit waffen an der
seite der armee kämpfen zu lassen das
natürlich hoch problematisch und im
prinzip ja ein rezept für disaster wenn
eine regierung so was macht das halte
ich für sehr problematisch
und das ist das was wir gerade erleben
die frage wohin das führt wird sich
sicherlich in den nächsten wochen zeigen
aber ich sehe afghanistan im moment auf
einem guten weg damit ist auch die frage
von sebastian stöhrer über youtube nach
der prognose wie die taliban jetzt
weiter agieren werden hoffentlich
beantwortet und ansieht eine
abschlussfrage die man natürlich alles
schon nicht mit ja oder nein beantworten
kann
was dieser einsatz wert die frage kann
man in der tat nicht mit ja oder nein
beantworten weil es ist immer eine frage
unter welchen welchen politischen
voraussetzungen
ich denke teilweise war es der
einsatzwert denn wir haben in
afghanistan einen zustand gehabt wo wir
es wirklich mit einem jahr gottesstaat
zu tun hatten
der menschenrechte aufs brutalste
verletzt hat frauenrechte aufs brutalste
verletzt hat wir alle erinnern uns
vielleicht an dieses symbolische bild
der afghanen in der brucker die im
stadium von taliban erschossen wurden
dieses regime zu entmachten ist
sicherlich kein falscher schritt gewesen
das militärisch zu tun
wahrscheinlich auch der richtige schritt
die frage ist nur wann man genug
informiert und genug darauf vorbereitet
was eigentlich im land passiert und mit
welchem land man es zu tun hat also hat
man die kraft der taliban wirklich
vernünftig eingeschätzt das ist die
frage
und da ich denke da muss deutschland
muss sicherlich auch die nato diese 20
jahre ganz klar aufarbeiten und jetzt
endlich die richtigen rückschlüsse
daraus ziehen aus der frage wie kann man
sich militärisch in einem land
engagieren
mit dem ziel dort demokratie zu schaffen
ist es sinnvoll und wie genau muss man
eigentlich wissen welche zustände man
dort antrifft sagt katrin eigendorf
vielen herzlichen dank dass sie im
studio waren und auch vielen dank für
die vielen reportagen und stiften die
wir nicht nur heute sondern auch auf dem
programm sehen und auch die expertise
die uns hier erhalten bleibt vielen dank
hat den eigendorf und ich möchte gerne
schließen mit einem statement von
philipp es über youtube der die frage
für sich persönlich ob der einsatz ist
wird war ganz klar mit nein beantwortet
aber und das wäre das allgemeine
schlusswort trotzdem allen soldatinnen
und soldaten großen respekt und
anerkennung ein gefährlicher dienst gut
versehen
wir werden weiter über dieses thema
sprechen über afghanistan und die
anderen einsätze der bundeswehr für
heute soll es das gewesen sein von uns
vielen dank für ihre meinungen und
fragen und kommentare und bis zum
nächsten mal schießen